sometimes you have to endure sometimes you have to
endure differing
opinions I'm also very
honest I'm a member of the FDP and I do
n't agree with many people what the
FDP is doing right now, so to be
honest, speed limit 130 on
German autobahns, yes, that will be easy  it would
make a lot of sense it would be a
super easy measure that would save CO2
and that would be right away and if you
feel like blasting across the street in your Porsche
then there are various
car racetracks in Germany
Nürburgring etc. you can drive on it and
then you just drive around there  yes, look,
today no one rides any more drives
on the German road yes that was at
some point everyone did it yes
and at some point they agreed no
if i if i want to ride horses
i go to the horse farm yes i can
continue  it's not a problem
why do I have to drive 270 with the German
autobahn, that doesn't make sense from my point of view